>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> CATHERINE HIEBERT KERST: Welcome.
My name is Catherine Hiebert
Kerst and I'm going to be talking
to you today about
Sidney Robertson Cowell
and the WPA California
Folk Music Project.
I'd like to thank the music division
for asking me to speak today
in their curator lecture series.
The collection actually resides,
both in the American Folk
Life Center where I worked
for many years, I retired last fall,
and also in the music division here.
There is also a companion
collection that resides at Berkeley,
UC Berkeley in their music library.
The Folk Life Center has the audio
recordings for this collection
and many forms of field
notes and correspondence.
And the music division has a lot
of information about the background
of Sidney Robertson, primarily
because she was married
to Henry Cowell for many years.
And since Henry's collection
is there,
many of Sidney's materials
are there.
But they are in some
sense overlapping.
I'm indebted to the staff
of the music division
who's helped me out a lot.
Nancy Seiger [assumed spelling]
did a beautiful finding aid
for the Sidney Robertson Cowell
collection in the music division.
And also to my colleagues in
the American Folk Life Center
who have always supported
my absolute fascination
with this collection.
They've heard me talk
about it at nausea I know.
And I want to thank the many
language and cultural specialists
in the library's European
division and the Hispanic division
who have provided language
and cultural background
for the many cultural groups that
are focused on in this collection.
I'm writing a book and
so, I'm getting a chance
to see what these songs
actually mean in their languages.
And I've gotten a lot of help.
So, I'm very appreciative.
From 1938 to 1940, while in her
young thirties, Sidney Robertson,
collector of traditional music,
single-handedly organized
and directed a Work
Projects Administration,
or WPA project designed to
serve a musical tradition
in Northern California.
The result of this new deal
collection project generated an
ambitious, multiformat, ethnographic
field collection called the WPA
California Folk Music Project
that I will speak about today.
Not only did the project
generate a wealth of musical
and cultural documentation from
a wide variety of cultural groups
at a certain point in California
history, it also provided
through the ebullient and
dynamic presence and writings
of Sydney Robertson, a vicarious
experience for all of us
of what it meant to do
ethnographic field work at the time.
In my experience, recorded
collections of traditional music
from the 1930s do not always
include much in the way
of documentary background and
may only list a song title,
the collection and
performer's names,
the town where the recording
was made, plus the date.
This collection has much
more contextual detail,
with numerous photographs,
drawings and sketches,
official field reports sent into the
WPA, a variety of other field notes,
and a wealth of Robertson's lively
reminiscences about her own work
and her often gossipy
correspondence.
It is a vast collection, included
35 hours of audio recordings.
I'll only be able to give you
a glimpse of what it contains,
plus a small amount of background.
But I hope it will wet
your appetite to browse
through the entire
collection at your leisure.
It is entirely online
here at the library.
Robertson was a dynamic and vigorous
presence, and eloquent spoke person
for traditional music
and its practitioners.
She was also a colorful
personality with very strong views,
perceptive of the graphic skills
in her own uniquely
patterned narrative style.
In a publicity file she kept,
Robertson described her new deal
folk music collecting efforts
dramatically in a bio that read
"Sydney Robertson Cowell is a
Californian whose adventures as a
"government song woman" in pursuit
of folk songs would
fill several books.
Before she married the
composer, Henry Cowell in 1941,
she had worn out three automobiles,
traveling over 300,000 miles
in her car in 17 states.
Alone with her recording
machine, her sleeping bag
and a companion once
described in her hearing
as "the lady about the songs' dog."
That is typical Sydney
Robertson verbiage.
Sydney William Hawkins was
born in 1903 in San Francisco.
As a child she was precocious,
articulate and inquisitive.
Her upbringing reflected an
independent and rather unstructured,
but open minded educational
philosophy,
progressive in character, but
definitely high cultural in texture.
She was given piano,
violin, dancing,
and elocution lessons
from an early age.
She had French tutors,
riding and polo lessons,
children's cooking
classes and much more.
When asked about her interest
in folk music collecting later
in her life she wrote, the first
ingredient was an itching heel,
which she attributed to having
accompanied her father as a child
on long business trips
throughout the west.
He would leave her for long
periods of time where she was free
to go exploring, as she explained,
he naturally felt a certain danger
in the extreme gregariousness
that I had inherited from him.
And so, the stock warning for girls
of that era, became a daily ritual.
Try not to lose your purse Sidney,
and never talk to strangers.
The trouble was I never
met a stranger.
From the ages of 10 to 14,
she accompanied her
piano teacher each summer
on Cook's Tours of Europe.
Robertson seems to have been present
at many memorable early 20th
century high cultural events.
And to have run into or met
royalty, famous artists, authors
and musicians in serendipitous ways.
In her reminiscences, she
writes of attending the premier
of Stravinsky's [foreign
word] in Paris.
She was in Rome at the outbreak
of World War I and in Paris
when German troops
moved into Belgium.
And on, and on, and on.
Robertson studied romance languages
at Stamford in the early 1920s,
married a philosophy
student, Kenneth Robertson,
travelled with him to Europe
where in Paris she studied piano
with Alfred Créole
[assumed spelling].
Kenneth studied with
Young, though Young appears
to have been more enamored
of her mind
and perceptiveness
than with her husbands.
When they returned to
California in 1926,
Robertson took a job teaching music
at the progressive Peninsula School
for Creative Education in Menlo
Park, and sat in on classes
about world music at the San
Francisco Conservatory of Music.
She divorced her husband in 1934,
and increasingly felt she was
leading too self-indulgent a life
in California.
Franklin Roosevelt had
become president in 1933,
soon thereafter initiating a wrath
of social and arts programs intended
to help the US recover
from the Great Depression.
It was in the spirit of the times
that Robertson moved east in 1935,
where she found a job directing
the social music program
at the Henry Street Settlement on
the lower east side in New York
and began to work with
recent Jewish refugees.
Here is Sidney in 1929,
when she was 26 years old.
I will refer to her as Sidney
Robertson throughout this talk,
because that was the name she used
during this period of her life.
She called herself Sidney
Robertson Cowell later,
after she married Henry Cowell.
It was in 1936, while visiting
friends here in Washington
that Robertson visited the
archives of American Folk Song
as the American Folk Life Center
Archive was called at the time,
where it was then part of the
music division here at the library.
Because of her many questions
about folk music collecting,
she was encouraged
to visit the Office
of Ethnomusicologist Charles
Seeger, the father of Pete Seeger
who was then in charge
of the folk music office
at the resettlement administration.
They hit it off and as
she explained, "Of course,
I got hooked on the work
and the wonderful, hopeful
and dedicated new deal so
that I didn't resist too much
when Charlie urged me to stay on."
It wasn't long before
Robertson had learned how
to work an instantaneous recording
machine and began to travel
on her own, collecting a huge
body of traditional music
and song throughout the
south and into the Midwest
for the resettlement administration.
In her car, with her
recording machine and her dog.
These recordings are
also here at the library.
This she pursued until
Seeger's Office
of Resettlement was dissolved
early in 1937, followed briefly
by a few months of folk music
collecting support of the Midwest
through the Farm Security
Administration.
When all of these sources of funds
dried up, Robertson began to lobby
for funding sources
that would allow her
to continue collecting on her own.
She traveled to her native
California, where she stayed
at her father's pig farm
near Fresno to seek support
for a state based project which
she hoped would become a prototype
for the collection of folk
music across the country.
After doggedly pursuing a variety
of funding possibilities
unsuccessfully,
like the Rockefeller
Foundation, she succeeded in 1938
in convincing the northern
California WPA Office
in San Francisco that
her project was one
that might be appropriate
for their consideration.
By this time she had secured
sponsorship for the project both
from the music department at the
University of California in Berkeley
and from the Library of
Congress' Music Division here.
UC Berkley arranged for
space and equipment on campus
and the library suppled Robertson
with 237 blank 12-inch
acetate discs for recording.
The trick within the WPA
was to device a project
that could keep 20 people occupied,
both to provide socially usefully
work for those on the relief roles,
and to justify the
hiring of a supervisor.
After working for Seeger, Robertson
was eager to be a supervisor herself
and not be beholden to
anyone else in her work.
She was also determined
to collect both English
and foreign language recordings.
Something that American folk music
collectors were just beginning
to do.
Robertson was not an academic,
and of course she was a woman,
but with her forthright
and energetic personality,
she found a niche for herself
in the fluid social chaos
of the Roosevelt Era, where in
other decades she might have had
more difficulty.
It was an era reminiscent of
our own in a number of ways.
Robertson devised and carried out
the California Folk Music Project
at fascist tendencies were
gaining momentum abroad
and populous sentiment
and the distrust
of immigrants was growing at home.
In addition, by 1938, the
New Deal Arts programs,
the federally funded arts programs
were facing increasing suspicious
across the country as being
frivolous and a waste of money.
She was well-aware of the
xenophobic tendencies of the age,
and prepared for pushback.
In Robertson's instructions
to workers that she wrote
for the workers on her project,
she instructed them to "remember
that the Anglo-Saxon music
which we are inclined to think
of as the only American kind is
a relative recent importation
on this continent.
Exactly as the Hungarian, Finnish
and Armenian folk music are.
The Portuguese and Spanish have
been in California three times
as long as the "Americans."
She also asked that her staff not
refer to the musicians and singers
as foreign, but rather called
them minority performers
to avoid widespread negative
reactions to the foreign born.
In a letter at the time to her
former boss, Charlie Seeger,
Robertson implored him when
talking to people in Washington
to please not use the term "American
traditional music" in reference
to her work in California,
because as she wrote,
I am trying to keep the
product description broad enough
to include Icelanders,
Hungarians, Basques, etcetera.
Everywhere people are not crazy
about "foreigners" though,
so I am also leaving out
the word American everywhere
and hope not to get caught at it.
She called her recordings
English language recordings
and minority recordings as a result.
Robertson had an uncanny
knack for unearthing WPA staff
from the California relief rolls
and she combed the files for people
who could help her with
her needs on the projects.
She found a Mr. Deviere [assumed
spelling] who had a dairy route
in Contra Costa County
and who led her
to numerous valuable
contacts along the route.
She also chose Portuguese
and Spanish speakers familiar
with their own musical traditions.
An Armenian ethnomusicologist,
a young man whose parents
had been performers
on San Francisco's barbary coast.
Plus photographers and draftsmen,
she thought would be useful
and would lead her to
singers she could record.
In her WPA project proposal,
Robertson listed a wide range
of activities to keep
her staff busy.
Everything from cataloging the
recordings she made to transcribing
and translating some of the songs,
researching old California
mission music,
San Francisco songsters
and much more.
The year before the project
began, Robertson was involved
in a car accident and the
insurance payment she received
as a result allowed her to buy
a new "baby presto machine"
as she called her portable
recording device.
She was delighted to own it
rather than borrowing one
as she had done for years.
At the time the Presto
Recording Corporation was an up
and coming company in the
broadcast and recording industry,
so that she could use her 12-ince
acetate discs from the Library
of Congress to record up
to 5 minutes on each side.
She liked the portability
and how small it was
and loved having her own.
For the California project,
Robertson defined folk song
in the broadest possible
sense, as "songs circulated
in the oral tradition and
discoverable in 1938 to 40."
She was remarkably uninterested
in finding the very oldest songs,
but rather wanted to document
what people were actually singing
in their homes, their
communities, their churches,
and at festivals and celebrations.
Often in context.
She wrote an article for "The San
Francisco Chronicle" a month before
the project officially opened.
And I'm going to read this.
It's a little long, but it gives
you a sense of where she's coming
from when she's looking
for music to record.
"Because our history in California
is yet so young, we are more aware
of the road, the dams, the crops,
and the bridges than we are
of the intangible accretions,
which have built up our modes
of thought and of living.
Every school child knows
that California's immigrant
civilization came from Spain first,
via Mexico and that the in rush
of settlers drawn by the discovery
of gold contributed strains from the
five continents and the seven seas.
And that California still draws
farmers and agriculture workers
of all kinds from the
middle west and the south.
How can we believe that
these successive waves
of hard-working citizens
contributed nothing
to California beyond
the work of their hands?
What traditions came with them?
Which have survived here?
Changed or unchanged.
What were they thinking and
feeling as they labored in mines
and forests, herding cattle
and sheep along our slopes.
Plowing and harvesting
in the valleys,
and fishing along the coasts.
Their songs will tell
us, if we can find them."
I think it's fascinating that she
uses the expression intangible
accretion because we
currently are always talking
about intangible culture and
the protection of it nowadays.
The California Folk Music
Project opened officially
on October 28, 1938.
At 2108 Shattuck Avenue in Berkeley.
This is a photo of
the employees at work.
Here is Mr. Prater the photographer.
On the back of this
snapshot, Robertson wrote,
Mr. Prater our wonderful Welch
photographer did all our developing,
printing and enlarging
for performers.
And the microfilming of California
songs choice from various libraries.
There are 168 photographs
of the musicians
and their instruments
in the collection.
She also found draftsmen
from the relief rolls.
And the collection
has numerous sketches,
mostly of the foreign
musical instruments.
Sketches on brown paper
and blueprint drawings
of the musical instruments.
And here is Robertson
herself making copies.
Robertson sought out the performers
and recorded all of
the music herself.
She usually spent five days a week
at the Shattuck Avenue office,
sometimes going out to record
with a number of them, the staff,
but also made recordings after
five and on the weekends.
There was no phone in the office.
Over the years she reminisced
and she loved to reminisce
in quite flamboyant ways
to set the record straight.
She was reminiscing about how
she did her collecting work.
She wrote, "I never asked
the singers to sing for me
or for the government, except
as a preservation project.
And I was never demanding of
them, if they didn't want to sing.
And we skipped it for the present.
And almost without exception,
they revived the subject
later themselves.
I was careful, just as a matter of
good manners not to say, I want."
In her early training at the
Resettlement Administration,
Robertson had experienced folk
music collectors who imposed more
of their demands on performers
than she though civil,
often ordering them to sing.
In response, Robertson consciously
forged a more approachable manner
with those she recorded.
She explained, "I wanted to convince
people that I shared their tastes
and values and that I
liked and understood them.
This is what has made a wide
variety of people willing
and even anxiously
determined that I should know
and record the best they had.
It had carried often past the
language barrier to simple people
who knew only that I found their
music beautiful and important
and that I wanted it
perserved as it truly was
for future generations to hear."
She also has written
about locating singers.
How does one found songs?
She asked, they are
everywhere at hand.
A man changing a tire
on Shattuck Avenue
in Berkeley last month sang
an old ballad as he worked,
and was startled by an
urgent request to repeat it
so it could be written down.
A receipt for a bill paid
to a railway express deliveryman
was signed with a Basque name
and this led to a whole
nest of songs.
I'd like to, throughout the
collection she does this very small
WPA announcement I thought you
might enjoy hearing her voice.
>> SIDNEY ROBERTSON COWELL: This
is one of a series of recordings
of California Folk Media made
by the Department of Music
at the University of California,
in cooperation with the Archives
of the American Folk Song
in the Library of Congress,
a diverse project administration,
official project number
665.8330, unit A 25.
>> CATHERINE HIEBERT KERST: The
range of foreign language songs
that she recorded is
quite impressive,
documenting 75 performers
in 12 languages.
From European and Middle
Eastern cultures primarily.
These recordings make up
about 2/3 of the collection.
There are love songs from
the Asturias in Spain.
And from the Basque country.
Hungarian Christmas carols,
improvised [inaudible]
from Icelandic settlers about
immigrating to North America.
Spanish serenades from
old California,
and [inaudible] Russian
Malukan hymns
from a San Francisco congregation.
Many of these groups had
never been recorded before.
I have chosen a few to sample
so that you can hear some
of this remarkable music.
I will focus on the foreign language
materials in this presentation.
Alice Lemons Avila was
a Portuguese Azorean
who had a Portuguese radio
program in Oakland at the time.
And she was one of the people
that Robertson chose
from the relief rolls.
She also did a lot of translating,
transcriptions and translations
of Portuguese songs and arranged
for groups of Portuguese Azoreans
to be recorded for Robertson
often in their homes.
You see her in the front left with
three other Portuguese singers.
She had a Portuguese guitar and
this is one of the scale drawings,
drawn by one of the
draftsmen, there are quite a few
of these wonderful drawings
of instruments throughout
the collection.
And I'd like to play a song.
She's accompanying herself on the
Portuguese guitar and let's see.
It's [foreign word].
This is a playful Portuguese song
form the Azores bemoaning the plight
of those who have no lovers,
whose faces look like raw parsley,
green lemons, or strained milk.
Those who are never visited
after dark by suiters.
It's actually quite
upbeat considering.
[ Music ]
Then I'd like to play
you a recording
that was made a Mexican wedding in
Carmel to which she was invited.
She met somebody on the street
in Carmel, who she had seen
and they started talking, and then
he invited her to this wedding.
It was a wedding of Ben and Rose
Figueroa [assumed spelling].
And the orchestra that plays
is Julio Gomez' orchestra.
It's performed in an ensemble form
at that time called [foreign word]
which predate Mariucci
ensembles of later years,
though this selection actually,
apparently is still a
favorite among Mariucci,
in the Mariucci repertoire.
You can hear the wedding
excitement in the background,
this is what I meant about
mentioning the contextual aspect.
[ Music ]
Actually, Robertson was
embarrassed at the wedding,
because the white boss of
Ben Figueroa was present
and got horribly drunk,
and acted horribly.
She was totally embarrassed
and wrote about it at length
in her field notes, how you know she
said I was one of the two outsiders
at this event and I was
mortified that you know
that his boss was making
such a ruckus.
Her field notes have that kind of
detail which is really wonderful
to read many years later.
Elinor Rodriguez was of
Puerto Rican heritage,
she was born on the mainland,
and she sings a beautiful bolero.
Robertson called it
Bolero Sentimental,
which actually it's a composed
piece by Puerto Rican composer
and musician Rafael
Hernandez, written in 1929
about the disastrous
economic conditions of farmers
on the islands during the 920s.
This bolero continues to be
one of the most symbolic songs
for Puerto Ricans I understand.
And it's also fascinating
that as a folklorist
and as a folk music collector,
she made no disparaging
comments whatsoever
about songs that were composed.
If it was song in a
community, she was interested.
So, this is sort
of a heart-wrenching beautiful
bolero that Rodriguez sings.
[ Singing ]
Another set of songs that have
nostalgic imagery and a deep sense
of longing for the homeland,
and there are many songs
in the collection that are
represented in that way.
This next one is a Scottish
song a scots Gaelic song.
There were a whole group
of beautiful scots Gaelic songs
collected in Berkeley in Oakland.
Here Donald MacInnes from the
Hebrides sings a moving traditional
song about sailing by the
island from where he is from,
and not having a chance
to actually go back home.
The lyrics in English go as follows.
"I see the land where I was a boy.
Land of heroes.
I will lift myself up
and go suddenly to you.
I see the land where I was a boy.
I see her at a distance
from me, veiled and cold.
And I am at sea on the back
of the waves in the Army.
[ Singing ]
The Gaelic songs are really
lovely, and very haunting I think.
Robertson also collected
many wonderful recordings
from the Armenian community
in Fresno.
Many of whom settled in California
after the Armenian genocide of 1915.
She recorded music in Armenian
cafes and at their picnics.
Bedros Haroutunian was a member
for Azoreans Armenian Orchestra
that performed at many community
events and that she recorded.
Jack Azlonian [assumed
spelling] told Robertson
that the group could play in five
languages, mainly Armenia, Turkish,
Greek, Arabic, and American Jazz.
Here is Bedros Haroutunian
with his qanun.
It's an instrument similar
to a zither with 30 strings.
The photographer on the project
took a phot of the tuning mechanism.
It is plucked and played
held flat on the knees.
So, here is "Song of Freedom"
and it opened with a qanun solo.
So, the zither like instrument.
[ Music ]
So, as they played they speed
up and this recording was made
on a Sunday afternoon at
Mr. Haroutunian's home
where the group often
played on weekends.
Robertson really wanted to
use the microphone to bring
out the solos, but
the group said no.
We all, we want to be one big
sound, we don't want any solos.
We want that affect.
So that was very interesting
that she writes about that.
An ode? And ode is like a loot.
Same family.
Yeah, there are pictures,
I don't really have time
to show you but they're wonderful.
Giuseppe Russo, he was a
Sicilian who also sang a number
of Neapolitan songs for Robertson.
He was a barber and as Robertson
wrote in one of her WPA reports,
she wrote, Mr. Russo has been
extremely helpful he has invited me
back over and over again, and says
I can come any day but Saturday,
because that's a busy
day for a barber.
He puts up the machine in
his house and dashes back
and forth when the bell rings.
Leaving me to wait until
he tends to a customer.
So, here is Mr. Russo
sings an amusing
and upbeat Neapolitan tarantella
about a man who wishes for more
than a kiss from his sweetheart,
and she's playing hard to get.
It's almost like something
from Opera buffa,
as far as my knowledge is.
[ Singing ]
The lyrics are quite racy,
I have learned [laughter].
Mr. Koljonen was a Finnish
American man, who Robertson met
in Shasta County up
in the mountains.
Boom Town was the name of the
town that rose up in 1937 and '38
when the Shasta dam was being
built and migrants from all
over the country rushed
there to get a piece of work.
And he came from Minnesota.
He and his wife ran Koljonen's Café.
And there are recordings
from inside the café.
He sings some Finnish songs, but
I thought I would give you a taste
of a dialect song from Minnesota.
So, let's see.
It's called "The Disgusted Swede."
Now, dialect songs were
commonly found in oral tradition
in the Midwest, and especially,
there were quite a few
in Scandinavian communities
that I know of.
They were comic songs about the
misadventures of immigrants,
usually sung in broken English and
usually about another ethnic group.
So, here you have a Finn
singing about a Swede.
And at the beginning I think
you hear, often at the beginning
of a recording you can
hear Robertson saying,
and please tell them the name of the
song, or where did you learn this,
or step up to the mic, or whatever.
And I always love that
bit of context as well.
>> All right.
>> SIDNEY ROBERTSON COWELL: Okay.
>> Shall I say the name?
>> SIDNEY ROBERSON
COWELL: Yeah, say the name.
>> This is "Song of
a Disgusted Swede.
[ Singing ]
>> CATHERINE HIEBERT KERST: As I've
mentioned 1/3 of the recordings are
in English, among the English
language songs one finds
for example, tunes from the
California Gold Rush Era.
Robertson sought out and
actually found, Sons of the 49ers
who were able to sing
old songs for her.
But she also recorded barbary
coast, rag time, and popular songs
from San Francisco, Cornish sailors,
chants and many other popular songs
from the turn of the century.
One character she recorded
was John Stone.
He was a fiddler, harmonica player.
And he had performed in the medicine
show routines earlier in the century
and in the previous century.
I want to play.
You see him, I mean she had a hard
time finding him because he was
up in his cabin somewhere
up in the mountain
and he would give cryptic
reports on where he was going
to be the next day and
she finally found him.
But she recorded this section
called "Dr. Ridges Food" in addition
to all kinds of other things
that John Stone performed.
This is an advertisement for baby
food that John Stone performed
on the Medicine Show
circuit in years past.
It punctuates sort of the
common narrative with song
that you find sometimes
typically in fable form and so,
I think you might enjoy this.
I always have enjoyed this one.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Well, there's an old song
that was used by Dr. Ridges
to advertise his food
for the babies.
[ Singing ]
>> CATHERINE HIEBERT KERST: And
I've actually seen advertisements
in old newspapers for
Dr. Ridge's food.
But it's a wonderful
document to have.
Roberson was surprised that
in the Gold Mining Territory
that she roamed in the mountain
there were few purely traditional
songs and ballads, rather
her understanding was
that the theatrical and musical
stage, entertainment that sprang up
and was offered for the Gold
Rush settlers from the middle
of the 18th century on really took
over and people, when asked to sing
or play an old song, it
often ended up being a tune
from the Medicine Show circuit
or from old California songsters.
Warde Ford and his brothers
were from Wisconsin.
They came to Shasta County to work
on the Shasta Dam from
northern Wisconsin.
Robertson knew the Ford brothers and
their extended family in Crandon,
Wisconsin where she
had recorded them
for the Resettlement
Administration in 1937.
Everyone in the multi-generational
Ford family had wonderful voices
and a wide repertoire of
songs about logging tragedies,
Civil War Ballads, love songs,
body and humorous songs.
And I'd like to play you one
humors song called "Barney McShame"
that Warde Ford sings here.
>> This song "Barney McShane"
learned from my brother Bo
who learned it from Walt Convert
from Boulder City, Nevada.
[ Singing ]
>> CATHERINE HIEBERT
KERST: During the time
that Robertson was recording in
Thalami County and Shasta County
up in the mountains she camped
out in her sleeping bag,
or slept in her car with her
dog on the side of the road.
And she writes about this sometimes
even in writing formal WPA reports
to the San Francisco office.
After 17 months of recording,
Robertson's plans for extending
and expanding the California Folk
Music Project had to be given
up when the expected WPA
funding was not renewed in time
for the project to go forward.
She had hoped that the continuation
of the project would allow
for recording and documenting
the performance of nonwestern
and primarily Asian music;
Chinese, Japanese, Korean,
which would have been
quite remarkable.
In spite of the fact that
the project was not renewed,
no other WPA field collection
of folk music undertaken
by a single person in
a specific region was
as impressive as this one.
The California WPA Folk Music
Collection provides a set
of recordings, a snapshot as
it were, representing a range
of traditional and popular music
collected during a specific era.
This taken as a whole also
tells much about the details
and the ethnographic field work at
its best during the new deal era.
It also gives us a glimpse of
the character of an energetic
and capable woman folk music
collector who through the existence
of the WPA had the opportunity
to take charge and carry
out an ambitious folk
music collecting project.
Roberson's successes in California
Folk Music Project fit well
with the new deal dynamism
and creativity
that generated similar
cooperative efforts to document
and validate the lives of exemplary,
yet so often unsung Americans.
I hope you have a change
to explore this collection.
[ Applause ]
If anyone has any questions,
I'd be delighted
to see if I can answer them.
Yes, oh, wait they're bringing a
mic, so if you just hold on a sec.
This, by the way, this image here
is from the online collection.
Which soon will be
migrated to a new format.
I'm not sure if this
image will stay.
But if you wanted to
find this collection,
you can just Google California Gold
Folk Life, that's wat I do instead
of remembering the whole.
>> And it's available outside the
building in the public website.
>> CATHERINE HIEBERT
KERST: Yes, yes.
>> I'll just explain that
one thing that's a little odd
about this collection in its
online home right this minute is
that it hasn't been
integrated into the Library
of Congress main search feature.
So, if you go on the front
page of the Library of congress
and you search for
an individual item
on this collection,
you won't find it.
And so you have to go
to this collection page
and so you should search
for California Gold
and you'll find the collection page,
and on that page you
can search and browse.
So, but I also had a question or
a comment as well if that's okay.
So, I think one of the great
things that you really bring
out about Sidney and her collecting
is that she was much better
than a lot of the male
collectors at the time
at allowing the community members
to be the authorities
on their traditions.
But one place where I think
she may not have done that is
with John Stone's recording there.
Because he very clearly said,
this is an old song called
"The Beautiful Baby" which
Dr. Ridges' food used
as an advertisement,
and yet the name of it
in the collection seems
to be Dr. Ridges' food.
And indeed it's an old [foreign
word] which you can find
in northern Ireland
and other places,
where it's called "The Darling
Baby" or something like that
and so have you found other
versions of that and found anything
out about the background of it.
>> CATHERINE HIEBERT KERST:
I found other versions
of it, yeah, as you say.
But I should mention that
now, I mean I have worked
with this collection over the
years, I'm discovering now that many
of the songs are, well the foreign
language songs are misspelled,
drastically.
And basically what happened
was during a recording session,
the 12-ince acetate disk
was put on the baby Presto
and the record jacket was there
for Robertson to jot notes
down including the spelling.
So, this is Dr. Ridges' food.
Then the WPA, you know staff
typed that into their lists.
Sometimes even the English
language songs are totally wrong.
There's the problem of
reading her handwriting,
and then there's the problem, I
mean of her not knowing Gaelic,
or Icelandic, or whatever.
So, as a result of this,
I think some of that will be
rectified in the catalog records.
Oh, sorry.
>> Fascinating.
Fascinating lecture Cathy.
I noticed the life dates of
Sidney, she lived into the nineties.
What was the rest of her life
like in a nutshell
after these recordings?
>> CATHERINE HIEBERT KERST:
She didn't record as much
as I would have loved her to record.
She married a famous composer.
She often was Mrs. Henry Cowell.
And she did some amazing recordings
in the Aran Islands in the 1950s.
She did a smattering of
collecting otherwise,
but she was a very
complicated woman.
And Henry Cowell died in 1965,
but she spent a lot of time sort
of being the composer's widow.
And his life was also
very complicated.
During this project he was in
San Quinton on a morals charge
and she would visit him, but
that's a totally different story.
And then she married him in 1941.
So, it's very complicated.
But some of her who she was
through her life had to do I think
with some of those events.
And yet, she wrote voluminously
and also spoke for hours and hours
into a tape recorder
reminiscing about Henry Cowell
and you know Langston Hughes, and
you know just all kinds of things,
and about his music and so on.
All of that is transcribed and
it's in the music division.
It's really quite remarkable.
So, it's not an easy answer.
And for me, personally,
it's sort of hard to read
that she became Mrs. Henry
Cowell after being so gutsy
and so self-sufficient
in so many ways.
So, it's a very complicated issue.
>> I'm sorry if I'm the only person
in the room that doesn't know this,
but you're talking about tracking
people down in their cabins,
what did the Presto run on?
>> CATHERINE HIEBERT KERST:
It was plugged into the wall,
I mean an electrical source.
>> So, the cabins,
wherever she recorded it.
>> CATHERINE HIEBERT
KERST: She needed a source
of electricity for that, yeah.
I think there was a
question up here.
>> Were there any areas where
her collection did not overlap
with things that the
Lomax's had recorded?
>> CATHERINE HIEBERT KERST: I don't
know much about any Lomax recordings
in California, but
in the previous era,
I mean during the Resettlement
Administration
and the Farm Security
Administration,
Robertson collected foreign language
materials just as Alan Lomax did
and actually gave Alan ideas.
You should be sure to see this,
go to this Finnish
community, or this, you know.
So, he was a lot younger than she,
but they were in communication.
And I would just say the more each
of them collected just
added to the bigger corpus.
Do you know what I mean?
>> I'm looking forward to the book
and this is a wonderful
presentation.
I'm wondering if you can say a
little bit more about their move
when she married Cowell, east,
because it does seem to me
that she gave up her
life in a certain kind
of way to save him maybe.
And also, this was around the
time of the beginning of the war
and how does this play
within what was happening
in the country at the
time of the war?
>> CATHERINE HIEBERT KERST:
I guess, I don't have much
to say about all of that.
Henry Cowell knew a lot
of the people she knew
from the progressive communities.
John Steinbach, I mean
she was a name dropper.
And he also knew a lot of, but I
mean she actually knew people too.
It wasn't just that
she was dropping names.
So, Henry Cowell had been her
piano teacher when she was young
and then I also know, I mean her
family, her father was a businessman
for the White sewing
machine company.
And I believe they lost a lot
of money during the twenties,
even though they were
quite wealthy earlier.
And she needed money.
She needed support.
She didn't have an
academic affiliation.
And so in a way, marrying
Henry, I've wondered about,
you know it gave her some kind
of a support and she would,
for instance she would go on
little field trips like in 1950
with Maude Carpoliese
[assumed spelling]
who was retracing the
steps of Cecil Sharpe
and Maude Carpoliese
from the 19-teens.
And Sydney wrote Henry saying,
oh it's so wonderful to be back
in the Appalachians, I'm
going to come back here.
And then I don't think she ever did.
I don't know, I mean
that's a whole other book.
Or several books.
Many layers of Sidney.
>> I have a couple questions I
don't know what your time is here,
but this is a fellow playing
a bag pipe and I would
like to know his nationality
and if you know,
when did she record and
music back from the.
>> CATHERINE HIEBERT KERST: He.
Mr. Biotical [assumed
spelling], he's Croatian,
I don't remember exactly
where he was from.
But I mean she recorded a
wide variety of instruments
that were unfamiliar to a
lot of people in California.
Then the three middle women are
the three Puerto Rican woman
who were friends and
who were all recorded
at Arura Caldron's
[assumed spelling] home.
I've actually located
Arura Caldron's daughter
who is still in Oakland.
So, I love having those
connections because from that era,
we're moving away from people
who might be able to be located.
Yes.
>> And one more question.
The Lomax recordings, did she?
It sounds like, I wouldn't
say collaborated,
but she fed ideas to him?
Did she actually ever go to
Appalachia and record with Lomax,
and that's kind of what I wanted,
is there any cross stuff going
on between them as far
as collaborating, you
know recording, or?
>> CATHERINE HIEBERT
KERST: Not with Alan Lomax.
Sidney went on a recording,
on a little field trip
with Frank C. Brown and John
Lomax, Alan Lomax's father in 1936.
And that was where she
was sort of testing
out how well she could
work the recording machine
for Resettlement Administration.
But otherwise I don't believe
that Robertson ever recorded
with Alan Lomax, though they
were very aware of each other.
And I mean he would have a radio
program in New York and say,
oh do you have any 49'ers
songs that I could play on the?
You know so they were colleagues
and their relationship was
a little thorny sometimes,
but I think they both respected
each other in a certain way.
Yes?
>> Seems like mostly
European extraction,
did she do any Asian recording?
>> CATHERINE HIEBERT KERST: No.
There are a few scale drawings,
blueprints of some Chinese
instruments because she had planned
that they would be done
in the second phase,
though I think it might have
been really hard for her
because of her lack of knowing
any other those languages,
though it would have
been fascinating.
Well thank you.
Thank you so much.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.